bonjour
quel est votre film d'
horreur préféré ghostface est de retour et effrayant comme toujours
c'est le moment de faire un nouvel écran
parce que nous avons une histoire spéciale à raconter
qui relie les membres de la distribution héritée
avec une nouvelle distribution dans le monde de
woodsboro
mon personnage sam devient la cible
du tueur de visage fantôme qui est cette
personne qui connaît votre petit secret
elle cherche dewey pour de l'aide
dewey il s'est retiré parce qu'il
a toujours un cœur énorme et veut vraiment
aider sydney elle a évolué dans sa
vie il s'est passé
trois attaques jusqu'à présent et  puis le chaos
s'ensuit
c'est juste le mélange parfait de nouvelle énergie
et aussi de garder ce qui le rend si spécial
en premier lieu je ne pense pas que ce soit
exactement ce à quoi les gens s'attendent
il y a des choses qui se passent là-dedans qui
sont un peu choquantes je ne peux toujours pas
crois que
j'ai vécu ça beaucoup, qui que
ce soit, va continuer à venir pour toi,
alors je veux que tu nous aides à le tuer
tant de rebondissements qui est le
tueur qui ne l'est pas nous ne savons pas les
sons  vous avez raison